bradley is gary a little bit nuts i got
so pissed off and i haven't talked to
you about this
what happened you guys were at some of
the work i got my ass kicked
yeah you're at the white house
correspondents dinner gary sees you and
he says hey bradley
when you get a minute can you come over
and say hi to my table yes you're a big
star you don't want to [ __ ] do
something
what are you talking about i'm sorry i
consider that we all have a nice day i
told gary that was amazing
i got big trouble about it because it
was a tape of it somebody was
interviewing you and at the end i said
hey would you say hello to the table
dude i hate when people do that but i'm
going to tell you off the air just so
you know
bradley forget on the air off the air
howard goes what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
like dead serious oh dead serious oh
dead serious i mean
you're a guy we know
what is so funny no not funny when you
did say that i did for a sec
i swear to god go ahead when you said
that because i was so happy to see you
and
then you did say that and i thought for
a second that doesn't seem like
something howard would want to do
no i swear to god dude that's right i
did cross my mind
oh you were right at least you know
bradley
he's worked with him for years and still
doesn't know i think
look if i'm at a thing and i know let's
say it's the producer of letterman or
something
that i know for years if he said to me
hey howard
you think he could come over and say i
didn't snap myself okay
if he said that tag you know what am i a
[ __ ] monkey
i'm gonna go over his table and you know
if he wants people can come over and say
hello to me i have to go
what am i going to walk over like a
child hi everybody i'm bradley
bradley by the way it's so awkward now
gary what do you do
bradley's all the time all the time and
it's like they're like oh hey what are
you doing
you feel like a jerk i'm not arrogant
i'm just saying i feel like an idiot
walking over to someone saying hey hi
i'm here i'm saying hi to your table
when you get there they're always like
hey uh yeah what do you want us to do
what are you doing here
so gary has been around long enough to
know that but he had absolutely no
governor on him
and he turns to you and he goes hey
bradley when you get a minute can you
come over and say hi to my table
like are you [ __ ] kidding me i'm
sorry
the only thing that hurt is because i
thought maybe because i was so psyched
to see you when i thought we were gonna
start talking and then you're like hey
do this thing
right that's the other card and i always
think that if i talk to you i'm
bothering you better to drag him to a
table
he turned around you make it sound like
howard inherited
what happened was i took gary a thousand
yards to go talk to her
gary why do you need him to say hello to
your table what do you get out of it
again i said there were a lot of serious
executives there there was
i was just trying to because you're
trying to be a big child sam
you're using the guy i wasn't using him
of course you are
somebody had just brought mayor
bloomberg over to the table sorry i
could say you don't know i should be
that guy
i guess i'm well aware of it i promise
i'm never doing anything i could ever
get really
just say hello to brad let's relive the
moment bradley cooper is gary delabotti
worthy
yes he's a big enough celebrity he's
worthy he's more than worthy we say
quick hello to our table
what is it when howard heard that at
once i heard that
at 5 50 in the morning when he heard
that shane look on his face
you